people are in tribes aren't they people
do come from families and tribes and
Nations and it's natural to have a kind
of affection for that and to offer some
Grace to that the family is a natural
Human Institution and political
communities progress naturally from that
patriotism is a logical extension of
filial piety I have no problem with with
Joy Behar saying yeah look Biden's on my
team and so I trust him more than I
trust the guy on the other team I wish
conservatives want to understand that a
little bit better there's nothing wrong
with preferring your family to somebody
else's family there's nothing wrong with
preferring your country to somebody
else's country everyone else on Earth
operates that way it's only these these
benighted liberals in the west who have
thrown all out that out the window and
said that no human beings are all just
undifferentiated individuals floating in
The Ether somehow we're all citizens of
the world Kumbaya no that's not true
it's not not how politics works